this week i'm in new orleans louisiana
home of ellen harry connick jr and
vampires
loud proud and full of flavor
i love this city and i think it loves me
back
what's up
it's a city defined by water for better
and for worse
new orleans i'm here to catch your fish
but i know it's not going to be the big
easy
oh big one big one
i can't wait to cast my line into this
unique urban gumbo
you never know what you might catch yeah
it's a dinosaur
i'm mike iaconelli my friends and i grew
up fishing the mean streams and rivers
of philadelphia
the bassmaster classic champions
now i'm a professional angler
with a screaming passion
[Applause]
for city fishing
all it takes is a little skill and a
local let's go to show you where the
fish are biting
welcome to new orleans
the big easy famous for its food
music art
and unique residents
a cultural melting pot that's over 300
years old
cajuns creole french african americans
native americans they've all added to
the unique flavor of the city
everyone loves to eat drink and party
and water makes it all possible
new orleans is super connected to its
waterways through commerce
through fishing and through flooding
the city is built on a thin crescent of
land sandwiched between lake
pontchartrain and the legendary
mississippi river that's why it was
originally known as crescent city
and not far from here the mississippi
river dumps it to the gulf this place is
loaded with fish and i can't wait to get
my hands on them
[Music]
but before i go fishing first things
first
i got to run in here and try some
absinthe
new orleans is full of traditions and
this potent green spirit is a classic
sign of the city's french heritage
this bar has been serving absinthe to
pirates generals and famous writers
since 1806. what are you in town for
i am here this week to catch three
different fish
the alligator gar
the speckled trout and the bull red
do you know any of those fish no
absolutely not but you do know you're
absent i do which one should i get
well uh do you want to fish sober do you
want a fish truck um
yeah
yeah all right um then i would recommend
the new bella orleans the nouveau's
gonna have the most wormwood so you're
gonna get more of that like stimulant
effect look i'm a fisherman anything
with worms in it i like
wormwood is a standard ingredient in
absinthe but there's no actual worms in
it it's a plan
i'm hoping it will bring me some local
new orleans luck
there you go okay
that's good to new orleans and the fish
of new orleans cheers
well i don't know if my luck has
improved but i definitely feel like i'm
back in the swing of new orleans now
this city is super special to me this is
the place where i won the 2003
bassmaster classic
never give up
never give up
this is the city where i got my start in
professional fishing
so before i start looking for my three
bucket list fish i'm going to
reintroduce myself to the bass of new
orleans
and the best part is i don't even need
to leave the city to do it
let me let you in on a little secret in
the heart of new orleans
there's a place called city park
it's 11 miles of lakes and lagoons and
this to me
epitomizes urban fishing
grab your rods grab a backpack and just
go fishing
city park is a treasure in the heart of
new orleans
1300 acres of waterways grand old trees
and fun for young and old
[Music]
you know the cool thing about these city
lakes you don't need a boat you don't
need a guide
you can do it all yourself i'll get one
there you have it
it's a giant
giant
okay so it's just a baby but i have a
strong connection with these new orleans
bass it's great to meet them again and
there we have
city park bass new orleans we're gonna
let this fish go
he's gonna swim away and hopefully grow
to be
big mama
lettuce
i'm on a whole school fish here
this is unbelievable
wait a minute
that's the same fish
it's not the same fish
number two
and you're getting bigger
okay enough goofing around
i gotta get along with my bucket list
but it's so much fun here maybe one more
cast
oh big one big one
look at that
great example
of urban fishing
this is a largemouth bass look at a
mouth on that thing
and they're eating little tiny bait fish
little minnows i made a switch to a bait
look at this
that looks just like a little minnow
made that change caught that fish
instantly wherever you're fishing but
especially in urban lakes
mimic the forage and you're gonna catch
bass even on your lunch break
damn i'm good
love you thank you
thank you
[Music]
what an awesome way to start my new
orleans fishing trip but now it's time
for some serious bucket list fishing and
first up i'm going after a prehistoric
monster that lives right in the middle
of new orleans
the alligator gar
taxi
this thing is a living dinosaur
i can't wait to get my first bite and
set the hook on this thing
my first fishing spot is one of new
orleans many canals this one is on 17th
street
a huge network of canals has been dug
around the city over the last 300 years
and fishing in one is a classic new
orleans experience
i'm hooking up with the guy in new
orleans that is the guy for alligator
gar mark hood
you came to the right place we have
plenty of garb you brought some rods i
have rods but i think i feel like i'm
under matched for these fish i've got
bass rods which might be a little light
you want to break one i think i'll take
mark's advice and use one of his rods
since gar can be more than eight feet
long and weigh over 300 pounds
an awesome predator with a mouth full of
razor-sharp teeth and scales so tough
that native americans use them as
arrowheads
hooking and landing one is gonna be
tough
that's much better that's awesome
that's gonna let it sit
you know the one thing that's
interesting is in a lot of forms of
fishing
an early start is key early in the
morning low light
but here it's different right you want a
later start with gar i want to wait for
the water to warm up because that's
what's going to make our active they're
a warm water fish actually they're a hot
water fish yeah
alligator gar live in the warm waters of
southeastern usa in lakes swamps and
rivers and hopefully
the canals of new orleans
because much of the city is below sea
level any water that enters new orleans
has to be pumped out again
our fishing spot is part of a series of
flood control canals that have been dug
out right through the city and they use
this pump structure to prevent flooding
in the city yeah
city's not going to drain itself right
so we got to use a series of pumping
stations to drain it
but this flood control system doesn't
always work
in 2005 new orleans was hit by hurricane
katrina
and 80 percent of the city ended up
under water
the big easy's canals and pumping
stations were overwhelmed
and part of the 17th street canals levy
collapsed flooding several nearby
neighborhoods
the walls have been rebuilt and pumping
stations strengthened
now it's a prime spot to catch an
alligator guard
that float went down did it
ah
there you go
somebody's eating it
what is that
look at it
he's biting it he's staying in one spot
though look look
there you go
he's on
he's on there
he's on there
oh it's a
turtle that was attacked
that was happened turtle
[Music]
thank goodness that's not happening to
me today
him got him
got him got him
look at that
another turtle
[Music]
good luck with that
this is a good way to sum up our day so
far
about four hours in
three turtles to show
it's not the alligator gar
but it's keeping us busy
it's turning into a scorching day
the water should be warming up and
getting those ancient giant fish active
it's having the opposite effect on me
i'm just about dozing off on the bank of
the canal
luckily we set an alarm
oh
we got bite
we got bite
i'm in new orleans
fishing for a giant prehistoric beast
called an alligator guard
this city is known as the big easy but
there's nothing easy about catching this
fish
see i'm running
just there i do see what
so he's still got it that floats down
yeah but we're waiting you're gonna be
mike you're gonna be my count guy you
tell me when i'm gonna be your running
for the net guy when they grab a bait
gar will swim off with it before they
actually swallow it
if i try to hook it too early i'll just
pull the bait out of its mouth or snap
the line on its teeth
and if i wait too long it might spit it
out
so this is the weirdest thing i've ever
done in fishing normally you get a bite
you set the hook you get a bite you set
the hook here
because these fish have uh teeth a long
snout
we're letting this fish eat the bait
he's got it right now that floats under
now this is a waiting game don't want to
wait too long to lose interest right
it's it's a happy medium about when to
wait and when to set the hook yeah go
ahead jack him up jack him
yeah he's got it
go go you jacked him
you jacked it right up out of his mouth
look at that
gotta jack too hard
i like the gar feeder i gotta be honest
with you it's been tough i got a great
idea orleans is full of canals yeah so
let's go see if we can find better
conditions on a different canal let's go
to orleans canal let's do it
the orleans avenue canal is another part
of the new orleans flood protection
system that lets water drain out of the
city and into lake pontchartrain
barely hear yourself think under here
what yeah you're right what we're like
underneath the freeway here we're like
trolls trolls fishing for gar
this is slow fishing
a reality of how we're fishing for gar
is you got to be patient you have to
wait them out
and the weird thing about fishing in an
artificial human control waterway is
that conditions can change with a push
of a button
whoa whoa what just happened oh they're
turning they're on
believe it or not that could improve our
odds the pipe just kicked on over here
looks like they're emitting a little bit
of flow you can see the white bubbles
coming out of that hole that might be
good i don't know i'm excited i was
falling asleep about an hour ago all of
a sudden i'm excited now
it feels like everything is coming
together
sun warm water and now some bubbles and
extra current to attract curious gar
he's got it he's got it he's got it
oh got it oh he's taking it my float's
gone my flow's completely gone this is
the one right here man i'm not setting
hook too early on this one
dropped it dropped it dropped it dropped
it
oh he's got it again he's got it again
he he's eating it spitting it eating it
got him there you go
got him
big one big one
big one
please please please get him in the net
play him over to me
that took a long time
finally happened now not a giant but a
good one look at that thing
look at the teeth on that beast
man you want to know why people think
they look like dinosaurs look at that
look at the mouth on that thing dude
look at the teeth look at the teeth on
that thing look at them the front ones
are like an inch long
alligator gar have a torpedo-shaped body
with small fins set far back toward the
tail
that broad snout is filled with two rows
of teeth long and pointed to pierce and
hold their prey
their tough overlapping scales are like
a suit of armor
and they can even breathe air directly
if the water is low in oxygen
no wonder they've been able to survive
so long
thank you mark yeah you're right thank
you new orleans
it took a while but i did it
my first ever alligator gar
tick that one off the bucket list
beautiful thank you look at this watch
this
all right guys
nice
one down two to go
who'd i say they gonna catch them fish
day two of my new orleans fishing
mission
next on the hit list is the famous
speckled trout
a speckled trout is kind of an iconic
fish to new orleans when i think about
this city when i think about lake
pontchartrain i think about giant
speckled trout
speckled trout or specks are awesome
looking fish with a bright yellow mouth
and giant fangs
they're a favorite sport fish all around
the gulf of mexico but new orleans is
famous for its specs
my journey to catch one starts on one of
new orleans iconic street cars
they've been going since 1835 and this
one the saint charles line is the oldest
continually operating street railway in
the entire world
we're going to be fishing lake
pontchartrain
but it's not going to be easy
cold this morning
a lot of wind and on top of that
a bunch of fresh water is coming in from
the mississippi river it's mixing with
the salt it's going to make fishing
tough
just a week ago an unusual event
happened heavy rain meant a flood
control spillway was open to divert some
of the mississippi's flow away from new
orleans and into lake pontchartrain
speckled trout prefers salty water so
that huge burst of fresh water could
have driven some of them away from their
usual haunts
luckily for me my guy today is a local
legend
captain dudley vanderbor has been
fishing these waters for 53 years
no wonder they call them the king of
lake pontchartrain
i'm mike what's got you in the fishing
my mom my uncle my grandfather started
me fishing for um freshwater trout
rainbow trout when i was a kid that's
what got me hooked it's crazy man
and now all these years later here i am
fishing for speckled trout in new
orleans
captain dudley knows all about the
spillway opening and releasing that
burst of fresh water so he suggests we
start fishing close to home
now captain dully we're going to start
in the marina why are these speckled
trout why are they in the marina why are
they using it we're getting a that's
that surge of fresh water coming across
because of the spillway and they're
trying to get out of it they're trying
to look for you know the highest
salinity they can find and these canals
will trap some of that salinity for a
while and then all of a sudden it
they'll take over even in the canals
there yeah
great place to start it's calm in here
it's protected we've got a big highway
going past you can hear the cars
but this is the kind of area where we
catch a speckled trout
there he is look at that
oh we got off oh god
you started to move that thing that was
a good one yeah
wow
that's a good sign
it was a pretty good fish we hadn't been
here five minutes
ready to get a bite
i mean until you get a bite you feel
like you have no idea what you're doing
whatsoever
i'm starting to think we're too late and
that freshwater surge has already
arrived in the canals
you know we're gonna make one more pass
to this area we've had one little bite
uh captain said it's not really
happening here but on the way out i'm
gonna switch up i'm gonna go to a
rattling bait
like most fish speckled trout have got
ears and can hear well i'm hoping a
change of lure might take advantage of
this it's a hard lure imitates a bait
fish makes a lot of sound and because
this is a real flat area there's not
much contour or structure or cover i'm
gonna throw this around just to try it
on the way out
the king of the lake has decided it's
time to enter his domain
lake pontchartrain
even though that fresh water has already
been flowing in it's a big lake and
captain dudley has a favorite spot he
thinks might still be working
lake pontchartrain forms the northern
boundary of new orleans it covers 630
square miles with an average depth of 10
to 16 feet
except it's not actually a lake
pontchartrain is connected to the gulf
of mexico so that means it's technically
a title lagoon
made a move we moved to a set of pilings
and we're on a bridge
we're fishing an old bridge here that's
not active but right behind us
is the main thoroughfare to get into new
orleans
the i-10 interstate bridge was built in
1965
to connect new orleans with the far
shore of lake pontchartrain
but when a huge storm surge blasted into
the lake from hurricane katrina in 2005
it got trashed
now a new bridge has been built right
next to it
and captain dudley steers us under the
remains of the old one to his secret
trout spot
this is a great spot to catch a speckled
trout
these pilings provide shade
they provide a break for the current
coming in and out and they attract a lot
of bait fish the one negative right now
is the wind
we've got a heavy wind blowing with the
tide going the opposite way and that's
stacking up the waves
it's making it really hard to fish and
really hard to feel the lore
hey
that was a good bite
another bite i missed it
this is looking promising
something down there is taking lots of
little bites at my lure
then the king of the lake shows me how
it's done that's a good fight though
yeah he's a nice fish
it's not a speckled trout but captain
dudley is giving me a fishing lesson on
his home lake ah come here and unlike me
he's not gonna catch and release
that's dinner taken care of
man i'm starting to think my new orleans
luck has run out
tough windy conditions
unusual things happening with the flood
control system
and on top of that i'm not feeling so
great
my throat's killing me i feel like i got
a head cold i might have a fever
it's hard to concentrate
but you know what the best cure for a
sick fisherman is
catching a fish
i'm fishing on new orleans famous lake
pontchartrain for the elusive speckled
trout
yeah
and this could finally be it
big one big one
got him look at how he ate that bait
oh my sideways in his mouth
look at that thing man one of the things
out here
dealt with extremely dirty water
we talked about it earlier
these fish
they have an ear
and listen to this
listen
that thing found that speckled trout
have streamlined bodies with distinctive
spots on their backs and top fins they
have a bright yellow lining around their
mouth and two huge canine teeth on their
upper jaw to pierce and hold their prey
look at it looks like a vampire man
that's a beautiful fish look at the
color on that thing look at the spots
the speckles down its back
captain i know you're gonna hate me for
this but i'm gonna let this thing go to
swim away and somebody else to catch
another there you go we'll catch you
here you go
there she goes
fish number two ticked off the bucket
list
that was hard work but i caught a
beautiful speck in the end captain
dudley i can't thank you enough man uh
it's always fun to fish with guys like
you and all and uh it was a pleasure
but i'm not ready to say goodbye to the
king of lake pontchartrain just yet
captain dudley said he's got a surprise
to show me back at his home marina when
we get back to the house and see if we
can catch a car for you you've got car
there got gar you're kidding me nah they
they uh
i call them my friends big ones or
i got some pretty nice ones huh
i've already ticked this amazing fish
off my bucket list but i only caught a
small one
i'm gonna take this opportunity to see
how big they can get with my own eyes
there is quite possibly a chance at a
seven to ten footer something that
weighs over 100 pounds do you mind if i
take a couple cases go ahead give them
good job you sure go ahead okay
they're used to being fed fish scraps by
captain dudley and his neighbors so it
doesn't take long to hook up one of
these giants
wow
well we're gonna need a bigger net
[Music]
man unbelievable
out here
and we've captured
an alligator gar this fish goes
well over 100 pounds don't you think
close to it 80 to 100 pounds
unbelievable creature prehistoric
looking it's great to see people looking
after these amazing fish
in the past alligator gar were
considered a pest and often killed on
site
they were wiped out in many areas but
luckily attitudes have changed they're
now appreciated as a top freshwater
predator and ancient survivor
this thing is a fish eater
eats anything it comes in contact with
and when you're this big
you can eat anything that swims in the
water just wanted to show you how big
and massive these things can actually
get we're going to let this thing go
back and somebody else can catch it
again
all right thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
i need a break
[Music]
that was heavy
no more alligators
[Music]
whenever i'm back in new orleans i love
to hang out by the mighty river that
it's built around
the mississippi
and share the joy of city fishing here
you take this
take a couple casts
the big easy was built and fought over
by many nations because of a strategic
position near the mouth of the river
whoever controlled new orleans
controlled access to the mississippi
and i should be more careful about
controlling access to my fishing rod you
want to happen down there i'll give you
five dollars if you can get it out
without breaking it off
five dollars if you can
you give me five dollars if i get it out
yeah all right five dollars if i get
this out
okay you ready for this one hold on
okay
okay
you owe me five ah mama kid
all right come on
look at his bird's nest and this guy
told me he could fish never let standby
passengers fish your equipment
well i lost my favorite fishing lure but
them's the brakes
i'm going to take a break from my bucket
list and do some mississippi fishing
just for fun
[Music]
we're gonna be doing a little sunset
catfishing
i just had to do it what's a trip to new
orleans and the mississippi river
without catching a giant cat
there are actually three different kinds
of catfish in the mississippi
flathead
blue
and channel
there are reports of blue catfish
weighing over 350 pounds
mark twain made mississippi catfishing
famous in his novel the adventures of
huckleberry finn
i'm meeting another mark to take me in
search of a mississippi cat hey how you
doing pretty good pretty good been
waiting for you
my garfishing guide mark hood knows a
lot about catching catfish too
he's taking me to a famous spot by the
mississippi the locals call the end of
the world
you ready i'm ready there's one trap
ready there we go two tracks there we go
keep going oh god
good man good man i gotta rest
i gotta rest with my back whew
that was the easy part hold on
let's keep going all right
it's been a tough trip and i'm still
recovering from being sick
mark is working me hard
whoa
wow this place really does feel like the
end of the world
it's definitely the end of a canal and
we're right where new orleans industrial
canal meets the mighty mississippi this
five and a half mile long canal was
built for cargo ships not flood control
it's 30 feet deep big enough for large
vessels to pass through
and hopefully catfish too
open your
eyes they're open i'm ready to catch a
cat
all right what's the plan talk to me got
two kinds of bait i got bluegill
and i got some old venison
ooh
venison meat it's really bloody oh it
wasn't aged well there's too much blood
in it so it should be good catfish bait
top secret yeah you're right
there are over 4 000 species of catfish
around the world and they often live in
dark and murky water
they rely on their sensitive barbels an
exceptional sense of smell to find food
let's hope mark's stinky bloody venison
bait gets these mississippi cats hungry
boy this this kind of fishing brings me
back to my youth man yeah you're right
it really does i did a lot of catfishing
as a young man it feels nice to be doing
this again
on the mighty mississippi
big catfish prefer deep water so we're
casting into the middle of the
industrial canal
sure enough it's not long before our
first bite
did you see that
i didn't but obviously you did
big jerk
reel it reel up to slack and see if he's
still there
nada that was a
that was a massive hit man we're gonna
get one they're out there
come on cats
it's getting dark don't you know you're
supposed to eat at night
well if we stay patient we should be
able to pick one up i believe you're
right
blue and channel catfish feed from
sundown to midnight so we're here at the
right time
but it's starting to feel like i'm
chasing my own tail
[Music]
i'm fishing for catfish on the mighty
mississippi we're at a spot called the
end of the world that's famous for
trophy fish
damn not again
it was down to the to the
ground well hot dog i picked it up and
there's nothing there
unlucky
it's not looking good man
been out here for a few hours
the sunset
it's got dark we haven't started a fire
and no catch yet
a few small bites but
not that big cat that we're looking for
oh well it's not a bad place to be
hanging out we're in the middle of
the city right now and we're standing in
one of the
the most renowned
trophy catfish spots dude i love that i
love that mix
of catching something wild
in a city setting it's the contrast the
contrast
the contrast between
natural and man-made yes this funky
thing going on
yeah
after hours of playing catfishing mouse
it's time to call it a night
catfishing on the mississippi is one of
the most iconic forms of fishing here so
i wanted to give it a
shot even though catfish wasn't on my
bucket list i'm a little disappointed
but it was worth a try and what a cool
experience catfishing on the mississippi
in the middle of the city
another beautiful day in the big easy
and i'm feeling great
time to track down my last bucket list
fish the bull red the bull red is
basically a really big redfish it's got
to be 27 inches long to qualify
redfish are relatives of the speckle
trout which means they prefer brackish
water
captain dudley the king of lake
pontchartrain told me i have no chance
of catching a bull rant in new orleans
city area
so i'll have to push past the city
limits if i want to land this one
[Music]
today we're headed to venice louisiana
they call it the fishing capital of the
world
and
venice is a really special place
it is one of the most amazing places to
catch fish
it is the spot where
the mississippi river dumps into the
gulf of mexico
venice is the closest i can drive to the
mouth of the mighty mississippi
after flowing for over 2
300 miles through or past 10 states the
river pours into the gulf of mexico just
a few miles from here
huge amounts of sediment are washed down
the river and it dumps at the mouth
forming a maze of islands wetlands and
waterways called the mississippi river
delta
[Music]
to me it's like a heart that delta
is constantly pumping
fresh water and oxygen into the gulf
and with that comes tons of fish
the sheltered waterways of the delta are
a nursery ground for a huge range of
marine life all of those little baby
critters provide food for hungry
predators
like bull rats
today i'm meeting sean
he's one of the guides down here in
venice and he's dialed on how to catch
these bull reds good morning good good
morning to you good to see ya looking
forward to taking a boat ride down river
and
trying to latch into some of these big
redfish
sean is originally from charleston south
carolina but he's been fishing in venice
for over 25 years
he knows the delta like the back of his
hand and he loves catching bull reds
but before we get out to bullred
territory i've got a special pit stop to
make
this is the exact spot
in venice
where i won the 2003 bassmaster classic
of course i was a lot quieter back then
man a lot of emotions running through me
right now a lot of things coming back
never give up
[Music]
if i hadn't won that event i don't think
i'd be here right now i think my life
maybe would have went a different
direction
i'm so glad we got to stop off here
i feel like my new orleans voodoo luck
has been all charged up now there's just
one thing left to do
catch me a bull red
i've had to head southeast out of new
orleans to the mouth of the mighty
mississippi river to catch my last
bucket list fish
a redfish at least 27 inches long also
known as a bull red
i'm in the right place with the right
guide and i'm ready for the running of
the bulls
sean we're at our first spot looks like
just a little protected bay
what's the strategy going to be here
we're going to grift we're going to
drift out here and open water because
the big reds just don't need structure
more times than not they're out here
instead of next to the bank
redfish are the largest member of the
drum family so they're like the speckled
trout's larger cousin
in spawning season male redfish can
gather together in huge numbers
but we're six months late for that
today our best bet is to look for
individuals patrolling the shallow water
this system that we're using uh is a
really really interesting system
and it's a a popping cork
it's
got a rattle to it it's got a cup on the
top of the cork which will trap water
and splash
so we're using the sound
but we're also using
that splashing noise
to draw the fish in
we started out in the open
but the key to fishing is to be flexible
in your thinking and keep an eye out for
what's happening around you
i'm kind of watching these pelicans over
here yeah and i want to change the
strategy we might come back to this but
yeah while they're there let's do it
doing it let's move over there hey one
thing i know sean the birds never lie
this area is full of seafood for both
animals and humans
louisiana's fishing industry is the
second largest in america and provides
40 of all seafood consumed by americans
each year
but pelicans have known about the delta
seafood treats for much longer than
humans
[Music]
hey god look at all the bait around him
look at all the bait
the debate's blowing up all around
this is neat to see the scenario and you
can see these pelicans diving like crazy
here and if you really watch
they're diving on
schools of mullet that are up in the
front part of this bay
and you know we're not fishing for
mullet but mullet are the food source
one of the food sources
for bull rats
[Music]
despite the amazing show the pelicans
and mullet are putting on for us there's
no signs of any bull reds yet
looks like you're popping it good to me
mike we just need to get it in front of
one of them that's willing to bite yeah
man this is this is a lot of work
i don't work this hard bass fishing
[Music]
man i'm getting cooked out here in the
sun and no signs of any bull reds
i'm starting to think my good luck has
run out
but you know what fishing's like just
when you think it's a bust
going bacon giant
oh big one big one
oh it's a dry ball it's a bullet to
baltimore
whoa
this is a big angry fish
oh my look inside this thing
now i've just got to wear it down and
land it
light line
this is 20 pound braid
on a bass rod essentially
he just caught a second
wind i thought i had him whipped then he
caught a second wind
oh my god look at the size of this bull
red ready i'm ready
yeah
yeah
right on
look at that
let's get this thing measured
it's a beautiful looking redfish
but to be officially a bull red it's got
to be over 27 inches long
this one here is uh 38 inches 38 inches
these fish are in the drum family
look at that thing look at that
beautiful
pinkish color at the top look at the
silver scales
here's one of the things i love about
these redfish look at that big
distinctive black dot at the tail
some scientists believe that the spot is
a fake eye that fools predators into
attacking the wrong end of the fish
the redfish's most distinctive feature
is internal in spawning season male
redfish attract females by making a
knocking or drumming sound
it's caused by vibrating a muscle in
their swim bladder and it's why this
whole group of fish are known as drums
this is probably i'm guessing this is a
three or four year old fish
so imagine what'll happen in the next 10
years of that thing
that's unbelievable
man this fish means a lot to me
that beautiful bull red means i've done
it i've caught all three of my new
orleans bucket fish
i'm heading back to new orleans a winner
yeah look how pretty that thing is look
at it in the sun
look at that
yeah
thank you
go back home
oh
well damn we caught a fish
accomplished
it's time to head back to the big easy
and as they say around here
libon temp roula
let the good times roll
man i love this city the people the
culture and of course
the fishing
i caught three out of three bucket list
fish and i've got to revisit the scene
of my most important tournament win
time for one last wander down bourbon
street
it's always sad to say goodbye to new
orleans
but i'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
you